hey what is going on i am so happy to be
finally introducing our brand new
podcast get close and i'm even more
ecstatic to be sharing this first time
with the brother with the family here
anthony lee
yay
thank you live audience it's a vlog
applause
all right so i'm your host gio and i'm
bart and i'm like i said i'm so excited
to have you here this is not the first
time that you've been on our podcast
yeah tell us about the first time like
how is it not the first time because i
don't know if our fans know that it's
not the first time it's not okay so it's
not the first time and i feel [ __ ]
horrible because i remember
like there was one point in the podcast
where you were like very moved and we
were all making like deep eye contact
and we were like connected all
watery-eyed too yeah and he was like he
had his hand on his chest remember that
and you were like i had never shared
this story before and it was like
such a beautiful once in a lifetime
moment
and it never aired yeah
why didn't it air guys there was like i
think it was a smile or two heartfelt oh
yeah
the whole thing was just broken no
really is that what happened it was
corrupted yeah i did not like it no
something no wow now something happened
with the audio or the video
where like i think you guys are telling
me something with the audio yeah which
uh
i mean are we even sure that this is
gonna work this time i hope so i hope so
man am i the first guest because it's
like you gotta get through like yeah
that's what we did to mike we just like
brought back season two and cage's
podcast yeah and then while we had him
come on i told him i was like hey we're
just finding stuff and we did the whole
podcast and i was like hey we gotta
scrap it we gotta try it again oh my god
yeah we're noobs though we gotta find a
float you haven't seen but you guys say
super professional i can't wait for this
episode to finally air
me too i hope everything goes good i'm
looking at that
this is the sarcastic look everything
goes good no okay so for everyone who
doesn't know and i'd be surprised if
they don't know who the hell anthony
that means they're a dumb ass
but not a lot of people listening they
already know who it is but i love
bringing on people that i really care
about and that i respect and i admire
and i look up to same with bart um we
only bring on people that we again we
admire and we want to brag about you man
because i feel like
that's just not how a lot of us were
raised right like a lot of us weren't
raised to like look at our our
highlights and then boast about it so
that's what we're going to do for you
today i want to boast about my friend
i'm getting nervous no and i actually
wrote it down so i'm a little bit
professional all right that's very
professional so
i want to see what bar did oh my god
that's this that's it's that's
disgusting this is my book dude okay
okay so if you don't know who anthony
lee is bro
let me introduce you dude
anthony lee is co-founder
creator
brain
brain child is
kinjaz
kenji's empire kid just consists of like
an apparel line it consists of like
dance studios that were like in the us
out in china
um you guys offer online courses you
guys have tons of a ton of students
teachers your crew is how big i think
it's like at least 30 people
46.
that's amazing that's a public school
classroom
it is and that's just like one of the
things like it okay you guys started a
noodle company called kinja bang noodles
uh
selling on amazon
just recently posted that you guys are
going to be selling it in [ __ ] costco
they are 40 something stores right 41
stores that's amazing i still there's
more there's more um you have
choreographed for c pop stars for k-pop
stars what are the stars
um any american galactic stars no no no
not american stars but mexican brands
trying to be humble i like that
uh no
honestly uh no actual american
celebrities which is totally okay um
however a lot of american
corporations and stuff gotcha wow well
speaking of american you've been on a
ton of american shows like abdc you've
been on world of dance um you guys have
even appeared had live appearances i've
seen you guys um do a dance for the
clippers
that's [ __ ] amazing you guys right
coachella
um actually one of our one of our team
members is uh the director for the
clipper spirit uh team and then so
brings in lots of choreographers so
that's really cool but the main
basketball stuff we did was actually for
the golden state warriors at the
halftime during christmas wow and you
guys were all santa's i remember we were
all saying that we we thought that was
really clever and fun it was yeah your
shows are [ __ ] awesome i love it you
guys always have like this really cool
fun element to it like you guys are
super fly and you guys have like this
really dope aggressive style but then
you guys will do like the funniest [ __ ]
like thank you i love it i love it i'm
not even done i'm not even done dude
you guys recently
developed the first nike dance shoe
like what
like that's [ __ ] amazing
okay still not done uh you personally
got engaged this year as well
that is a yeah selfie pops yup self
processing yeah that's nina she's uh
studying downstairs yes life milestones
dude yeah no i mean and like
i don't know man i i i feel like i keep
going on and on and on don't forget the
biggest of all time oh host of jake
that's crazy
we can talk about that that's a come up
baby no no um but no dude like i i was
telling you like before we came in here
i'm like dude i was writing down like
just the accomplishments that i can
recall off the top of my
you know off the top of my head and i'm
like holy [ __ ] like you've lived a
[ __ ] awesome life
like you have achieved so much that a
lot of people can't even wrap their
brains around like you guys have uh like
the studios you guys have apparel you
guys have the noodles you guys have just
the crew and like just just within the
crew itself to have so many people and
have
them all be just
[ __ ] die hard about it like it's not
easy it's not easy like injecting that
type of soul into so many different
people that came in from so many
different walks of life you know so that
is a huge accomplishment man i you know
i i sit here and i yes thank you so much
for going down the highlights that was
fun that's cool um i'm sure i missed a
ton of [ __ ] too i just i just feel such
a poetic irony
right now because uh
which we talked about on the first
podcast that never went out yeah so we
have to just talk about some of those
things again yes yes um but like
to
have accomplished all that and and i
haven't gotten a chance to let that
settle i'll be honest with that some of
the crazy stuff that has just gone down
i'm like i'm still way my head's in the
clouds on it i have no idea how to
process it i'm literally my feet are not
on the [ __ ] floor i've been jumping
out the window almost every weekend
finding out the next piece of news the
next piece of news that even here being
excited to show even new stuff is like
really really cool but thinking about
where it came from also why i'm here
sitting with you guys talking about
where it came from that's where i see
the poetry um
i will never [ __ ] forget one of to me
still to this day one of the most
important conversations that i had was
in uh a spot that we called bangoria it
was a living situation i was living with
mike song jason bueno you know our homie
rob who's a chef uh we were living in
this monterey park house on wandering
drive which was like two minute drive
from kendrick's dojo um and
i
was first i moved into uh that spot as a
what was i a shabu-shabu
server i think that's what it was i
think i was serving shabu-shabu trying
to keep the dance streams alive
and so i had a one-on-one conversation
with jio and i needed i genuinely was
alright i need to start asking people
for advice
right and uh part of that dance journey
wasn't just about trying to become a
dancer or choreographer anything like
that it was trying to figure out how to
express it how to use social platforms
how to uh almost like foundational tools
and tricks of the trades on not just how
to become an influencer but to do it as
a boss to to find like the lane to be
um more of an entrepreneur as well
because that's that's some of the
examples i was getting from y'all not
just seeing you guys and being like oh
they make they make film videos that are
funny like that might have been like the
way to easily describe jk films at the
time but i saw you guys building exactly
what you're talking about what we try to
do with like an empire you know having
merchandise having different channels
having different pods of organizations
that represent different things whether
they be the party sector the new sector
the the the skits working on a movie
building up a [ __ ] this is not my
podcast by the way you guys are my
guests what's the [ __ ] i don't know
building a gym all that stuff like it
was it was easy for me to get um
positive influence so i remember sitting
in my house and uh humbly asking eugeo
and danielle was there too
you know like how
i could do it i only i think the
conversation and the questions were that
basic i was just genuinely like uh what
advice do you have like how can i do
this thing with kenja's and how can i
pursue this and you just as a homie as a
sister back then like and that was that
was 2012
or 13. it was either 2012 or 13 so
definitely a solid seven eight years ago
now
you know and uh i'm just one of those
guys that like that was so important and
core of a conversation and a moment
where i was like i'm gonna take this
advice and i'm gonna run with it and
that's all i've been able to try and do
just [ __ ] run you know what i mean
and like heed that advice and take it
like wholeheartedly so to sit here
there's like a poetic justice to like uh
the irony of being like i feel
uncomfortable as you're like giving me
props because like you should get some
props for you guys cells for like
inspiring a a young calendar don't do
that no you can't do that thank you for
tuning in
there no i'm gonna give geoprops you
can't do that so like i have to that's
what was missing the first podcast that
was the heartfelt moment i was like this
i have to share this people don't know
this yeah thank you that's beautiful i
gotta hold your hand no homo just for a
little bit yeah yeah yeah
that's cute and i appreciate that
um
but like
i don't know man like i feel like it's
it's
it's
i i just feel like that's just what
homies do you know like we just always
want to see each other win and [ __ ] so
um i appreciate that you took it that
way and you took it to heart and like i
mean i do expect the percentage of
whatever it is that you're making up
that's the difference right you give
like hella homies advice but not all of
them are always like you know right no
they don't i [ __ ] take advice like
you did
i'm like i have to take it yeah but i
mean you're still trying to be humble
and that's not what i'm trying to hear
bro like i don't want to i don't want to
hear you be humble like i want to brag
about you i want i want or we want to
brag about you you know what i mean okay
well one more one more humble thing i
have to say then at the very very least
like i'm very [ __ ] proud of
everything that kendra's done but like
for sure for sure you guys know that's
not all me there's like a whole crew a
whole team behind it absolutely anybody
who like you know is is hip on kindred
and stuff and and the very least like i
would have never been able to do it like
uh without you know my geo my bart like
my mic song you know what i'm saying is
like i to to have somebody to like ride
and die with that whole time is very
very shout out mike song that's what i
have to do now we can brag about me it's
all about me now okay yeah we've set the
record straight oh yeah and nina's still
yes at all the things that you've done
though uh i mean like the list goes on
right but is there something that
you are the most proud of whether it's
in your career or not in your career oh
that's what could be life ones too
because you know a lot of people no
that's super deep man like for me i
think
yeah it's cool like doing all these
things when it's your own personal
passion right and you're just doing your
hobbies and it's kind of like it has a
uh it's driven by a little bit of
selfishness not in the the bad
connotation but in what your personal
interests are yeah but now that i have a
kid or even when we got married it's
almost as if it doesn't really
matter how much it interests me
if on the end result if there's nothing
that benefits us
then it almost isn't even as fulfilling
if it only benefits me you know and i
know you you guys have a big ass crew
too so i'm sure like
there's much more consideration of
things that just benefit you or benefit
you
and your fiance but what also what about
like your crew or you know your life or
your parents for sure for sure i love
how you're about to answer this really
deep question with the [ __ ] bandana
and he has like a fur cape on with the
kazoo going out of his mouth and he's
dropping some knowledge bombs yeah he's
like going historical political [ __ ] and
you're sitting there it's like this
shirtless ass dude with his [ __ ] feet
on the table yeah yeah yeah telling me
about mongolians like three hairs coming
out of his nipples
oh my this guy is just crazy
and he's looking at you and he's like
what are you looking at yeah yeah like
you're the problem what's wrong with you
yeah
um
okay first first answer that come on uh
i don't know this is gonna sound like
some i guess not superficial uh but i'm
gonna say give it a [ __ ] just go for it
uh
i'm really proud of
uh kinderbang noodles more cuz like
how the [ __ ] did we get there yeah you
know what i mean i think um
one of the things that i remember
remember what was the name
mitchell yes mitchell yes you [ __ ]
know me mayor of moderation
like this the homie most most standout
thing he ever said to me again that i
like i [ __ ] don't know sometimes i'll
hear advice maybe from my parents and
that shows just go right out the other
ear yeah but then sometimes people
randomly say something at that unique
time in your life and it just sticks
right and i remember his photos just
[ __ ] lecturing my ass and half the
times i'm like yes mitchell just yes i'm
i'm down for you so i'll listen right
and this time i was like oh [ __ ]
that's really good advice and he was
like you guys know the story i bet you
said the same [ __ ] [ __ ] to you guys
he's like
you know
the gold rush and i was like yeah he's
like you know the miners that went to go
get the gold rush i'm like yeah yeah
he's like
do you know who actually got the most
rich during that time or the most
successful i'm like
the
miners right he's like no it's actually
the ones who were selling them the
shovels and the pitchforks it was
actually the people that were like uh
building the hotels out there for the
miners and their families to stay in you
see it's never just about like the
person who's like in the spotlight it's
about the industry that builds around
right because he was talking about the
ufc example about the things that
started ufc yeah yeah yeah yeah right
but then the same story exactly right
same [ __ ] story just like trying to
relate it to like your own [ __ ] right
talking about how it's like it's not
just about the fighter it's it's like
there's a whole world tap out can get
built you know i mean brands and all
this stuff so don't just think about
what you're doing think about everything
that revolves around that industry and i
was like that's very very
good advice especially at my age right
so i was like
dance can't just be my thing it has to
be a half step and a vehicle to
everything else i have to use it as a as
a means to get me from place to place
not as the thing that is the place i
want to be at so actually even to this
day i i don't actually look at dance as
my like my thing
the irony
for real honestly it's my vehicle it
takes me to places it gets me places you
know uh and and we only knew how to take
a half step out every single time dance
is super close to like fashion so we're
like yeah we should make apparel dance
is close to music so yeah let's produce
some
dance is close to health and fitness
blah blah this and that
but to get like
noodles is like a full step i don't know
if that's like a half step yeah it's
like you you were like oh it should be
vegan like nutrition but it's not like
we're going into things like barbell was
doing you know what i'm saying like
building a fitness gym or programs or
like creating like creatine or whatever
the hell you guys like pre-workout that
by the way i want that um that new boba
flavored pre-workout and here we go
brown sugar brown sugar that's one
screech sorry to interrupt here but i
wanted to talk about our sponsor
skylight frames thank you so much for
sponsoring this podcast i absolutely
love this digital frame
as we know the holidays are right around
the corner and you want a gift a unique
heartfelt gift right you don't want to
just get any generic gift from anywhere
you want this gift to come from the
heart and that's why i'm so happy to be
talking about skylight frames which is a
touch screen photo frame that you can
email photos to
and they appear in the frame in a matter
of seconds i got this gift um or i got
this frame for my mom
last year for mother's day and it's been
the coolest gift that keeps on giving
honestly because as you guys know we
live in nevada now she lives in
california
so i mean we live in a digital era so
i'm always taking pictures of you know
of of my son tyka or just adventures
that were that we go on and it's super
rad that all i do is get those videos i
mean get those pictures sorry um and i
email them to her frame and like i said
in a matter of seconds she has them in
her frame in her rotation without her
having to do anything because let me
tell you my mom is old school and
technology just isn't her thing and if
she can use it trust me anyone can use
it it is such a freaking cool gift
right now you guys definitely want to
get in on this you guys want to put in
your order before things get nuts or
you're doing last minute shopping so
take advantage of this because right now
um we're gonna offer you guys ten
dollars off your purchase of a skylight
frame when you go to
skylightframe.com and enter code bill be
aw
yup hooking you up with a 10 off
deal on your purchase of a skylight
frame just go to skylightframe.com and
then to code bill b e a w that's s k y l
i g h t
f r a m e dot com and enter code bill
and thank you to our sponsor anna louisa
that is creating the cutest chicest
trendiest most affordable jewelry on the
market right now i own a few pieces of
uh anna louisa i have a couple rings um
i have some hoop earrings bracelets and
a couple necklaces and let me tell you
they are so damn cute that you can dress
them up or dress them down and it's
gonna elevate any
outfit that you wear so um you're
wearing you know denim and a t-shirt
don't worry hook it up with some anna
luisa jewelry and it elevates it and it
looks so cute and it doesn't look too
done up you know what i mean like it
looks like you're trying but like not
too hard um but let's say you have a
fancy dinner or event to attend at night
keep the jewelry on change the wardrobe
and boom elevate it again fit in the
perfect setting fits in every single
setting
don't miss out everyone listening right
now we're gonna hook you up go to
shopanalouisa.com
bill and go treat yourself or your loved
ones
use the code bill be aw to get 10
off
again i absolutely love their jewelry um
it dresses up dresses down fits perfect
for every single location um so just go
to shop
dot annaluisa
slash bill
enter code bail b-e-a-w and you're gonna
get 10
off do not miss out trust me thank you
to better help for sponsoring this
podcast all right we all know the
importance of mental health we all know
that it starts within us whatever it is
that we want to achieve in life or
whoever it is that we're trying to
connect with or just being a decent
member of the society i think it's of
paramount importance that we are happy
within that we are happy with ourselves
so if there's something that has been
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
then better help is going to be for you
okay so better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist all
right
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis hotline it's not
self-help you're literally communicating
with a professional
therapist um it's gonna be done securely
online so you don't have to worry about
leaving the comfort of your own home or
for some of us
uh that live in you know rural towns or
cities we don't have access to a lot of
you know uh professionals out there so
it's always good
to know that better help
has your back so right now for everyone
listening we're hooking you up with a
special offer
um you're gonna get 10 off your first
month that's the first 30 days
10 off at betterhelp.com
slash a bill you have nothing to lose
and literally everything to gain
i mean this is only going to let you
know
what it is that you need and you're
going to be talking to the right people
that is going to help guide you get
everything that is that you need so go
to betterhelp.com
bear
that's better help b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash bell b-e-a-w uh or
amphibious shorts that you know what i
mean like like we went [ __ ]
noodles and this was a drunk
conversation that like um me mike and my
boy alex you know a partner had because
he was making cb uh consumer um packaged
goods as well and we were just
connecting after 10 years since i used
to work for his clothing company and
stuff you know so when that happened
how did that
come about with three drunkards honestly
me and michael probably just arguing
again for like the 18th time about like
what was better ramen or pho and it's
not it's really not even for me like
it's not wait which one did you pick
i'm a [ __ ] guy oh come on but i love
ramen so i don't hate on it i just have
to argue with mike it's like naughty you
get it it's like not yeah yeah me and
him are married you know what i'm saying
that's like i'm the biggest fan of ramen
but hands down fur
see that's what i'm saying like i no
dude
we were just born this way yeah yeah ram
is delicious it's al dente you got the
egg noodles for sure right look you just
sold yourself what
when you are down in the [ __ ] dumps
and you're sick and you have body aches
what do you want what is gonna be the
theme that is gonna nurture your soul
pho hits you in the soul
it really does i think ramen hits you in
the taste buds and you're like you know
it's like a like a head high
fuzzy
[Laughter]
i could have the shittiest day but if i
go to a good place with literally four
chairs and there's flies in there and
it's only
five bucks for a bowl yeah and they got
the thumb in the soup like when they
hand you the soup the thumbs inside yeah
i mean and then and the water tastes a
little bit like the soap and you're on a
plastic kid's chair the little kind of
yellow ones that you find in like
chinatown yeah but your first slurp
done you're already transported into a
different place
all right hands down okay it's like it's
like the critic when he eats ratatouille
at the end of ratatouille
that's fun to me so it doesn't
necessarily need to be the illest thing
on the menu the most expensive it just
takes me somewhere else gotcha and i
didn't even like when my friends uh
first introduced me to it i'm like ugh
vietnamese people eat dog food because
that's what it looked like to me because
it was like [ __ ] white noodles look
like dogs
it's the other stuff it's the tripe the
honeycomb whatever the god all the other
crazy tendons [ __ ]
you're chinese what the [ __ ] are you
talking about i know but i grew up
vegetarian oh okay so like my hair
vegetarian yeah my mom's my mom's
vegetarian so like the first half step
was me eating like chicken in the shape
of dinosaurs
yeah
so like so anything outside of like
steak or perfectly cut piece of meat it
was like
uh it wasn't appetizing you know and
that's when i saw like [ __ ] white
honey
like coagulated blood yeah
i was like yeah [ __ ] i'm like did you
guys get this at the back of another
restaurant and put it in here
but now it's my favorite food vietnamese
easily top three one of my favorite
favorite foods
yeah so so to answer your question i
think like
knowing and being that person that i am
with what i want to do with dance and
stuff like that too in terms of what to
be proud of i always wanted it just to
be a cool vehicle and i'm proud of the
places that i've stopped along the way
with it
right now obviously nike is a whole
different level of pride that i'm like
again i'm my head's in the clouds with
it yeah thanks for stopping
yeah thanks for still being our friends
after that yeah
yeah but the noodles is just the most
like how the [ __ ] did we get here and
how is it even like this much of a
conversation still like how did we not
[ __ ] just fail yeah how did you guys
just push it forward were you guys just
like
[ __ ] it let's just for shits and giggle
see
like
i think me and mike like we learned what
we were good at and we learned exactly
what we're not good at you know what i
mean one of the things that we're not
good at is if we want to build like a
another thing associated with our brand
or another company at the end of the day
it's not like we have the bandwidth to
run another company we have the
bandwidth to like be associated with or
like build put our licensing on it or
like you know uh engineer some of the
marketing or the way that it's maybe uh
brought to our consumers but at the end
they like we can't just build a new food
product run everything from from the
financials to the packaging to the
logistics and negotiate with every
single distributor well you sound lazy
finding um the right pretty much
specialized producers to become partners
with was the thing that like we uh
really learned because before i think we
were always trying to do everything
ourselves yeah and do it in-house and
like you know we got to do it from the
ground up we it's got to be our own
taste we're the artist blah blah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] the pandemic really kind
of like you know made us put on our big
boy pants because you know a lot of
things just kind of changed for us good
and bad
all silver lining but like you know
finding the right partner is what
enabled us to get that far so once we
were able to work with alex in his
strength in his field than just
combining who's one of the partners in
canada yeah um who is who's he's
actually one of the co-owners of
kindergarten and he's actually our
appointed ceo for the company same thing
for even me and mike to like humble
ourselves and be like hey you know what
we shouldn't be [ __ ] running the the
business of this thing we have to run
the organization yeah from like an
internal from a community from a team
but like there's so many other things
that we stop to direct running the
actual business and ensuring that it's
going to survive especially when you're
doing business with friends you know
what i'm saying making the right calls
yeah me and mike were like we're going
to step away from that position so that
everybody still can win yeah and then we
could take out what our actual
superpower is what brought us here in
the first place whether it be our
creative or whether it even just be our
people
communication skills to keep the family
feeling like a family you know what i'm
saying like so that's that was a hard a
hard thing to like understand about
ourselves but that's also what enabled
it to go as far as it has like really
recognizing you know um
strengths in other people and weaknesses
in yourself but that that's what makes
the hole bigger you know
nice i like big holes
nice and i cannot lie
no that's [ __ ] dope that you guys
were able to
um see that in business like fairly
quickly right because i think that's
just like what a lot of people kind of
get stuck at even me like i think i just
learned maybe this year um that yeah we
all have our strengths and our
weaknesses and kind of figuring out what
that [ __ ] is is always [ __ ] hard and
then being able to look at yourself and
be like that's not you or this is you so
move in that lane or get out of this
lane you guys do a good job you guys are
[ __ ]
in the thick of it right now obviously
again [ __ ] shout out get close brand
new branding new podcast show new
[ __ ] house in vegas like you know
like moving on and evolving different
sectors you guys stuff like being even
for me just keeping constantly
throughout the years always traveling
but always trying to be back and be like
hey i'm back let me just see if i can
get in jk news or whatever just staying
close has constantly given me
a [ __ ] cool shining example again
there's millions of ways to get to the
top of the mountain you know what i mean
but at the end of the day it's like the
examples that you look at the ones that
relate with you you guys [ __ ] know
how to evolve [ __ ] and adapt and i'm
like that's what needs to be done
because we were holding on to a lot of
the old stuff the old way and uh in a
new world right yeah especially post
pandemic it's like some of those stuff
just doesn't doesn't hold up so like
we're we're in a heavy season of just
adapting but yeah really really proud
that the we're still alive to be honest
because some some groups and some
companies you know didn't really make it
in our scene
it's sad like uh because you know when
you i don't think anyone saw the
pandemic coming so everyone has a dream
except for the leaders of the world some
people did yeah yeah those [ __ ]
say paige bro
you know like talking on monterey park
that's like my stomping ground from like
15 until
you know like as a reason right
and seeing how a lot of these mom and
pop shops have killed it for literally
20 years
and then the pandemic comes which no one
saw coming on that street they're like
of course they're gonna try to stick to
their old ways and not evolve into the
new world right because they're like
i've already been doing this for 20
years this will people they don't even
know how to start yeah this will pass
and then you go down garvey avenue and
there's literally only three restaurants
open
you know you're like [ __ ] that sucks the
pandemic was straight survival of it was
natural selection like emotions aside
not trying to be uh i'm not i'm talking
about businesses i don't want to talk
about that for a [ __ ] human species
element um but from the concept of
selection yeah yeah like when
when a whole it's like noah's ark right
like water came out wiped a bunch of
people and like only the people either
had support financial backing uh
other things to rely on during a weird
time like you guys were telling me how
um [ __ ] luckily for you guys with
barbell the pre-work on all that stuff
came out right before it was perfectly
timed if not for that i think we would
have been under two yeah and it was we
had we didn't see that coming or
anything like that the pre-workout was a
was a result of having tycha and i was
exhausted and i just couldn't find any
type of pre-workout that i felt like
that was going to get me through the
type of workouts that i wanted to do and
so just throughout out of necessity to
try to stay awake during workouts but we
created that and it just so happened
that you got close fans you see you see
why i brought my two guests here today
why they're so
so a lot of the things that
you guys do it's a big
it's a big family
venture right we all got to do this
together we reap the rewards together
and that's what we see from the outside
and i think um
that's what
that's what's awesome about having a
team but also
the teams are made up of team mates
which are individuals
and so like
one thing i always wanted to know is
out of all the things that you've done
right and like let's say the world does
end for some reason and you're on an
island by yourself or you're just by
yourself for some reason
post-apocalyptic
what is something that you've done
that you feel like you can pat yourself
on the back for you're like you know
what i know i live in this world by
myself
but [ __ ] that was tight you know oh
that is a good question
i mean
again my head's in the clouds but right
now the [ __ ] nike [ __ ] that we just
did yeah is like uh
for the culture yeah i think uh legacy i
think the word legacy comes by yeah like
we just talked about the noodle stuff
yeah that's like [ __ ] cool yeah
that's not like necessarily like my
legacy yeah you know what i mean um
but with what we just did with uh being
the lead consultants and uh co-designing
with tinker hatfield
the new dance shoe for nike and it's not
like
it's not like um not payless
[Laughter]
it's uh
what am i trying to say
if i were like a sick ass basketball
player in today's world it's like like
kyrie or something like that yeah i need
to make another shoot it's not like
there are all these other shoes before
me kobe's and jordan
it's this is like there's no other
concept of this before to the point
where when we had to go and do uh shoe
testing for this thing and like actually
before they even developed the shoe they
needed to learn about how dancers move
so they had to take us in with our
regular dance shoes whatever we normally
get down with and they had to do like
you know those scientific studies and
measures do you wear like converse and
other shoes i don't know
all right well converse is owned by
nike's okay good point technically it's
fine all right but like if we were
rocking shell toes it was just like
literally they were saying show up in
what you show up with that's not the
point just show up in what you show up
with so we go to campus and uh they take
us down in the innovation center where
they do like lab testing actual lab
testing and it takes this basement and
the hangar doors literally look like
[ __ ] you're just in a bunker is it
like some dude with like a badge like or
like retina scan type [ __ ] or like
everything from like the craziest nda's
i've ever signed in my life to like you
know to badges and fingerprint [ __ ] like
it's like
it's like some white house type [ __ ]
it's sick
and you go down there and it's like they
take us to the basketball room because
there's no dance room like that's how
that's how brand new where we're at with
this whole thing they don't even have a
name for it or category and they're
they're arguing on whether or not it
should even be called dance you know
what i mean like there's so many it
could be a movement shoe exactly exactly
um so there's a whole whole
world of things that they have yet to
figure out where did where the guinea
pigs you know there's actually a
bittersweet feeling about it because
like we maybe started a dialogue we
didn't answer any problems we just
started dialogue you know and i mean
moved the needle if you will but that i
think is that's enough for me to be
proud of in terms of the legacy because
there wasn't something beforehand so
even if we [ __ ] up the fact is it
happened and now now somebody can build
off of it you know what i'm saying i
remember sitting um
yeah they took us to where the
basketball uh people going there to test
their shoes because there's a there's a
basketball court so the flooring makes
the most sense for us it's not like
we're going to dance mainly on turf
right so we go to the basketball floor
and there's a clear window you know on
the floor that has like weight sensors
and stuff cameras and lights so they can
track your foot movements clear yeah
just just a square like where the free
throw hole is right and then and then
toby hatfield tinker's brother comes in
and he's like sitting down with me yeah
yeah and he's huge he's a sick ass vp of
the nike that kills it too by the way
from an internal in the shadows yeah
cause i never even heard those but i
just know that the legendary shop right
anyways um and he sits down with me
because i'm like sitting on the side
while other guys getting tested and
stuff and he's like
how you feeling and i was like this is
crazy uh this is i can't believe we're
here and he's like yeah uh lebron
recently was testing his stuff right
there amazing and i'm like my god i
don't even know what to do with that
information you know what i'm saying
like you're just like
uh okay yeah that's all you there's
nothing oh yeah i can't even measure the
weight of what that means as a dancer
because there's no other experience
before us you know what i mean and uh
even just sitting in it like the the the
bungalow where they do like their crazy
innovation meetings with tinker and
being like
and and trying to
be of an ambassador for dance even
beyond kindred and just trying to say
honest things not yogi sick like it had
these colors because our brain you know
it had nothing to do with us yeah it was
genuinely even being like
um we're a little worried that uh
like
one shoe is not going to cut it like
dancers are fickle there's a lot of
different types of movers like a ballet
dancer is not going to kill you know
what i mean and it was one of those
moments where he had to seriously be
like like we know that uh this isn't
going to be the answer for the entire
culture
but
people at the top people who make real
decisions for these kinds of things even
on behalf of nike sometimes they need
something to understand and believe in
and it starts with one thing you never
go well if you don't make the calls i'm
talking the wrong person
but you you know what i'm saying it's
kind of like that's what you need so
like i think that's what we did we we
started with one thing
and if that were like the entirety of my
dance legacy i could honestly hang up my
shoes and be proud for myself even if
people don't understand the weight of
that you know what i'm saying because we
did that in the shadows too like for
four years look at that the branding
never changes in the showers for four
years not allowed to talk about this
[ __ ] you know what i mean for four years
we've been doing it since the end of
december 7 2017. and the thing is like
straight up i started when i was 31 on
that project i'm 35 now wow but but
here's the bittersweet part imagine a 35
year old basketball player in the nba
maybe they have great stats and legacy
and all this [ __ ] but not that good yeah
like you're looking at the [ __ ] 20
year old that's killing everyone you
know what i'm saying and that i'm
i'm humbled to like be a part of you
know this moment for dance but i also
have to humble myself and understand
that like somebody else is meant to pick
up these shoes and do something with it
you know what i'm saying i also feel
like
like i don't know if you feel this way
or if other people perceive it this way
but because there has been no other
model for it
it's almost like um your guys's version
of going to space
you know what i mean yeah like for like
jeff bezos elon musk or whatever it's
like yeah we're using technology that
exists now but we're going into a
frontier that no one has ever been
we don't know what the uses of that
frontier are we just know that we need
to get there because that is obviously
the next step we've been staring at a
telescope at a moon for decades now
so it's like yeah dancers wear shoes and
the
athletes they move around and there
hasn't been a shoe designed for the
needs of a dancer so we have to take
that next step and who knows what
happens after that like you could
catapult a giant industry or it could be
nothing i think with the momentum of
paris 2024 olympics uh officially having
breaking yeah an involved b-boy and
b-girl in there that momentum plus where
we're at
this is like the moment like if there
was a moment of momentum that could push
the needle enough
for some [ __ ] out there to
suddenly be like let's put this [ __ ] on
espn let's make a reality tv show about
it let's do a netflix docu series about
like a crew and follow it let's like
they do um that other you know like the
basketball the football documentaries
for like high school teams and stuff but
yeah like there can
it doesn't just have to be dance moms or
like a studio ballet nutcracker stuff
that's like traditional that people
understand like there's there's a whole
world
and we just need enough momentum at one
time for the right people to kind of
pick up and and you know it's almost
like institutional money for bitcoin
this is i feel like we're at like 2006
or 2009 for bitcoin but for like dancers
you know what i'm saying um and you just
hope and believe in something ideal
about it but we'll see we'll see who can
pick it up later thank you so much to
skillshare for sponsoring this podcast
guys
how long have we all been working from
home how i mean honestly how much time
have we all gained from not having to
get ready in the morning to not having
to make breakfast or cook or just run
out the door grabbing a banana or
whatever is that you can for breakfast
sitting in your car
waiting in traffic and then going to
work
getting your work done and then
repeating the whole process leaving work
coming back home all of that time that
you have saved skillshare is here to
help you optimize it so that you can
learn a brand new skill um do you want
to be a better photographer do you want
to be a better interior designer or not
even better do you want to start all of
that skillshare is hooking you up with
so many cool classes on art on writing
on business um you name it they're going
to have a class for you i have an iphone
and i am on instagram and i want i i
really wanted to take better pictures
and i didn't think that i needed better
equipment to do that i'm like hey this
iphone is so cool so what did i do i
went to skillshare
i looked at all of the courses that they
offer and sure enough there was a course
on how to optimize your iphone in taking
the best pictures and let me tell you my
picture game has
changed significantly like i'm doing
pictures where i'm like turning the
phone completely upside down and it
comes out so red i highly recommend that
you sharpen those tools of yours or just
finally
do something good for yourself and learn
some rad ass skills
for everyone listening right now we want
you to explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
bell and get a one month free trial of
premium
yes premium membership that's a one
month of premium membership at
skillshare.com
bill
b-e-a-w
thank you so much to one of my favorite
app games best fiends
right now
y'all need to
download this game because it is such a
fun
cute family-friendly game that requires
no type of internet so i know a lot of
us are starting to get back into travel
and we all know that when we're in a
plane for the most part there isn't free
wi-fi but you don't even have to sweat
it because you don't need it to play
this game with best fiends you play
through an actual story line which is
really cute complete with good guys
which are the fiends and they're not so
good guys the guys i hate which are the
slugs all right so the fiends they're
all these cute little insects that are
trying to protect this garden from these
nasty ass slugs that are trying to like
invade and kill everything it's super
cute because there's multiple levels per
theme and once you finish that then you
change to completely different themes so
you start off i think like on a farm and
then eventually you end up in the place
that looks like alaska or antarctica
it's just like a bunch of ice everywhere
and like the themes change constantly
you're never in two places
uh or you never see the same place twice
is what i meant to say
the graphics are so vibrant so happy
and it's actually challenging like i
find myself really trying to like um
like figure stuff out it is the coolest
pastime that i do for myself when i'm
just trying to unwind
definitely definitely check it out best
fiends download it it's for free
download it today at the apple app store
or google play that's friends without
the r okay best fiends
on the on the people going to [ __ ]
space and stuff like that right you see
those memes where the first people that
landed on the moon or like the first
spaceships that went out there is like
way less technology than like today's
modern iphone yes like everybody in
their own [ __ ] cell phone has way
more technology like tenfold than the
tech they use to get
humans onto the [ __ ] moon that's what
it feels like where we're at right now
like the dance journey with like this
kind of
movement
that's crazy that like abdc and all that
is like
when bitcoin was under a dollar
so what do you know
for cruz for cruz for like that
especially
but even in like the dance world right
like i remember
when
the the first inception or concept of a
dance star
when before it was like oh you got janet
jackson and her dancers yeah all back up
yeah but now it's like no the dancer is
the star yeah and that concept that
changed was crazy and that's what we
were we had to use back then to even
like get our name out there before
everybody would literally be like uh
like if a dance workshop was happening
it would be like janet jackson right and
then like choreographer or dancer of
blah blah blah like on the flyer you
would always advertise the artist the
credit or the industry yeah madonna's
dancer exactly yeah you wouldn't even be
like i don't even [ __ ] know who this
person is but i know they carry out for
this person so it's maybe a credible
class to show up to like that's how it
always was every single time you know um
and you had a few sick ass anomalies out
there you had like wade robson's you
know what i mean you had like people
like popping taco who was training
michael jackson you like you would know
of a couple things but like
it wasn't until like our generation
youtube generation uh abdc on tv type
generation that like suddenly yes
suddenly it all turned around and even
especially uh not just turnout for
dancers but for even like asian specific
dancers you know what i'm saying yeah
like having a chance to
build your own industry if the regular
industry didn't let you come play with
them no i think it's [ __ ] tight and
it's a true testament of who you are as
a person um because you keep doing this
and and i know you're not doing it
intentionally but like you keep uh
we we tell you something good that
you're doing and you're like but it
wasn't me it's this whole thing right
um
and i get it like like you know it
always feels weird to have the spotlight
on you but i think you as a person for
you to like
carry this this this weight on your back
that you really didn't have to do right
like if this whole nike thing is
happening you could have just been like
why i mean and it wouldn't be wrong if
you were just like yeah let's see what
we can how we can incept kinjaz into all
of this and make a
some type of collab with nike and kinjaz
and only focus on your crew but like for
you because i mean that's one thing i
love about you is that you don't operate
off of scarcity and you're never like
the type of person to be like oh [ __ ]
this is my [ __ ] this is the only thing
that i'm going to ever have and this is
everything that i am so i want to
protect it at all costs you're all about
like the community that you build
whether that's with dance with your
homies like it's it's a beautiful thing
man and i think that's what really has
you know propelled you obviously your
work ethic obviously you know whatever
it is that you put into anything that
you're passionate about all of that hard
work all of the [ __ ] tireless nights
like i've seen you like you you'll do a
podcast with us and then right after
you're like going into meetings after
that you're going into another podcast
for your own [ __ ] but it's just the
ability
to like always wanting to give back to
like the community or the people that
you love that like we absolutely admire
about you you know because you didn't
have to go into this nike deal and be
like yo this is tight like this is the
conversation that we're having for you
know my community of dancers you know
like you're like i know i'm not going to
solve a problem but like at least the
conversation started like that's so dope
like i think i think yes like with your
question of like you know what are you
going to be proud of um
you know if you're uh it's
post-apocalyptic you're on the stranded
island and now you're like going back
into your memory space and going okay
what am i proud of what are my
accomplishments i from what i see
i think it's the ability um
for you to just
uh
[ __ ] i lost my turn i thought god damn
it that's so good
uh
i have to take it back and butter it up
all from the beginning and i want to
hear all about jesus it's just because i
was just feeling it but um even just
your answer right of you saying like oh
the legacy that i'm leaving behind it's
like dude that's still such a humble
answer you know it's the it's the fact
that you're able to
like really care about people at the end
of the day
like it really is that simple like the
how much heart you have for people that
i think is a really beautiful thing
because a lot like i said a lot of
people would go into a lot of these
things saying well how can i come up how
can i have my legacy for my [ __ ] come up
but for you it's like
yo like i did this for everyone i care
about and that's such a self like
selfless thing to do i think that's
[ __ ] beautiful
thank you ah so i got through it my bad
dude my bad was there ever a point
where like because obviously you know
success is in a straight line
um there's ups and downs like crazy
and sometimes without the downs there's
no ups and sometimes right after the
highest peak there's the deepest valley
you know
um was there ever a point where
you're like
man i [ __ ] regret doing this
or i regret this happen or i regret this
about myself
but then later on you're like
i'm so glad that happened because that
made who i am today
dude honestly this year this year i had
the strongest
feelings of
you know you always want to be like i
don't regret [ __ ] you know what i mean
like you try your best
way of everything you have to have a
silver line about a boss so you like
coach yourself yeah but at the end of
the day like you're saying that in your
head but your body's like going through
[ __ ] remorse so you know what you're
saying like that was this [ __ ] year
for us
it was supposed to happen
again
not to be so pandemic-centric but like
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy like that
wrecked everyone our children won't be
able to understand they'll go through
their own like war time with their own
pandemic potential you know this is like
our war time right this is like our
[ __ ] vietnam war this is it hopefully
but uh um
like we oh [ __ ] dude this is this is
still even hard i haven't even processed
how [ __ ] much i went through my own
remorse but we had to
we were pretty much partnering with our
chinese partner sign up stage in order
to open up um the [ __ ] world's
premiere
creative dance blah blah blah center you
know in the heart of los angeles this is
some real [ __ ] like describe it i've
been there oh my god we called this
place at the complex we you did go oh
okay okay that's the one yeah okay yeah
yeah you know we we our regular studio
brand was kendra's dojo right it's just
supposed to be on our theme it's not a
martial arts studio you go there you
[ __ ] learn the way the king just blah
blah dance dance dance which is all sick
as [ __ ] i know you're downplaying it but
we're here to up play that [ __ ] and it
was sick as [ __ ] and it was not which
was for us you know obviously but the
point was for the complex even more sick
like state-of-the-art uh film center and
you know me for our production team
vibrancy uh executive meeting place with
conference conference rooms so that we
can like conduct our business or bring
different partners there heart of los
angeles which meant it was [ __ ]
expensive yeah but it was like in the
heartbeat of l.a so how many square feet
was it we were talking over 11 000
square feet or something like that it
was like 12 000 square feet we had our
own back out we renovated this place we
went into a five-year contract a
five-year lease deal yeah with with
options to extend because we were so
bullish on like
if you want to [ __ ] i mean you
weren't wrong though
before pandemic yes you weren't wrong
that's that's the um
that's the hard part right you you can't
anticipate those things but at the same
time you have to no matter what you
can't no you can't complain about it you
know it's not like oh pandemic therefore
it's like everybody had to go through so
you're still in a state of like not
really being able to complain because
everybody's going through it yeah it's
not like somebody [ __ ] you over or
even that you [ __ ] up it's just like
oh this is happening and this is the
this is where my bag that i'm left to
deal with at the end of the day right
and this spot we did we did our grand
opening
end of january 2020
which is literally um the day before the
day uh the week of our grand opening was
also the week that we did like our uh
our uh 10-year anniversary for kinjaz
and uh we were sitting down with the vp
uh of nike in the complex so we're like
everything was like
if there was ever a time for me to be
like i'm [ __ ] crushing it right now
yes [ __ ] on top of the world i was
like grand opening our complex ten year
anniversary of kenja's like we made it
this way it's like wolf on dance street
vp of nike is like
and then when they're in this facility
we're meeting with nike and they're
impressed by where we're at we're like
i'm impressed by where we're at you know
we are [ __ ] impressed like not by
space but even by moment in time with
nike and then in that meeting i will
never forget nobody will ever forget
this moment in that meeting my [ __ ]
phone buzzes right and i'm not super
unprofessional but i look at it real
quick and then it's nina so i have to
like double check just in case [ __ ]
nina man [ __ ] nina
hey hey
we love nina we love you and and it's
all caps and it's just kobe died
[Music]
that's one of the moments everyone knows
where they're at exactly and i'm in a
[ __ ] nike meeting kobe nike like of
course so i go
and then obviously in the vp was like
just talking so every everybody
everybody knows i'm not a dick or
anything like so they're just like okay
share it and i'm i don't know what to
say to these people because like i'm a
fan but maybe you're
you're like you're working with them or
you know people that are like totally
impactful or i'm like
kobe died
and they're like what and then every the
meeting immediately gets cancelled
everybody's looking it up they see the
confirmation from 16 minutes ago
helicopter blah blah blah this and this
and that they're immediately whispering
about their co-workers like do you think
this person knows bob weather and then
the meeting ends and i swear that moment
literally from from kobe's death was the
downhill spiral for the world
for the world right
so then right after that even our
banquet was like a little bit weird we
had to like when was the banquet the
uh later that day
oh that we found it when the meeting
ended was like people just putting their
stuff with him i'm so sorry but there's
bigger issues that we have to deal with
pretty much that was literally like
we're like hey let's table this is a
great conversation thank you for like
blah blah blah but like we understand
and literally it ended our meeting god
that's crazy so it probably flew down
too right so then we really need to
blame nina then because it could have
been a big [ __ ] deal yeah god damn
[ __ ] nina
and then and then airplane mode bro
everything spirals from there right and
then the [ __ ] run once covey goes in
then it's like the grand opening of the
complex suddenly everything went
and then we had to shut down and it was
like and then it was like holding on for
a long time and we're trying to figure
out during quarantine this whole ppp
thing yeah other people are getting fat
ass loans we were like doing our best we
were getting no barely any financial
support so they're like [ __ ] we just
opened the complex but okay
at the end if we want to save the body
we got to amputate like a limb so we're
like
me and mike had to make this the the
crazy call we're like do we
do we shut the complex down do or maybe
we could shut the dojo down first like
if we cut the dojo maybe we can hold on
for this much longer but we'll hold on
to the complex
you guys trying to hold on because you
guys were hoping it was going to end
soon yeah we're hoping it was going to
end and also we just built it we were
still on a five-year lease we had just
spent over a million dollars oh my god
over a million dollars
renovating all that and bringing it to
code god also bringing it to code with
the city in l.a which is yeah which is
horrible crazy so and it took us two
years to do it so we we signed the lease
two years prior to our grand opening day
yeah so like
it was it was this much momentum and
then getting to that moment even with
nike like i said i felt like i was on
[ __ ] top of the world because it also
took two years open spot shout out to my
team for putting in a lot of the work
obviously yeah um and then
and then it was just decision after
decision just like we got to close the
dojo if we want to think about keeping
confidence close the dojo had to come to
a settlement that wasn't easy you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah
you break at least you gotta come to
settlement that was a financial
situation
[ __ ]
a couple months later
no end in sight the complex is kicking
our asses we have to have the second
serious conversation we had to close
that down that was [ __ ] difficult by
the way because our landlord was a
penis yeah um but i'm almost like penis
bro so is it a good thing or about this
penis it's terrible oh it's thinking
penis okay that's bad it was terrible
i've never
felt such unique feelings towards a
human being oh [ __ ] that sucks yeah um
but it is what it is and we got through
that you know what i mean and we had the
same thing app you amputate that
and but that means you better believe
that there's like a two three month
maybe i'm still feeling certain things i
don't know a period of time where i'm
sitting at home and like we're trying to
remove me
i don't have any more studios in fact we
also have to close our one of our
complexes in shanghai that one also is
in the
last stages does it feel like um
like you know i feel like you know jk
started in a bedroom right and as you
build i think when you start having an
office
and you start having like material or
physical things the
idea of the dream becomes more and more
real like when we first got the jk
office i i remember like
monterey parker the downtown the
monterey parkway yeah even though it was
small we still shoot jk news now but
like now when i tell people like we're a
production
studio or production company it doesn't
feel like it doesn't feel like a lie
even though on paper it's never a lie
right because if it's a llc and you make
content professional for sure for sure
it's not a lie yeah but when you're
working out of like a two-bedroom house
it it doesn't feel legit
so now that you have
the greatest dance duty of all time
and
you lose that
does it feel like it crushed
you and you're like the crazy thing is
is
it wasn't just that that was like the
biggest tangible thing which again when
you receive
over a million dollars for a project
only to go away like literally and again
it's not your fault
like that is one thing right but in the
same time like remember like out of our
five studios like two of them already
closed one was gonna close still uh we
also had three uh we had a major dance
competition you guys went to arena both
the adult and the kids division in la
singapore and china all shut down
because live events
right yeah our other major form of uh
income or an income in general for our
brand right was live performances which
were ex-nade right and group
performances yeah teaching and traveling
which was ex-nade because you can get
into a spot
so like every tier the only thing every
revenue stream the only thing we had
going for us was we [ __ ] sold masks
and that we weren't even prepared to
sell that much because we didn't know
the massive man was going to [ __ ] go
8 000 higher yeah so we were sold out
and that was good and the the little
stock that we did have we were killing
it yeah but even then the irony with
that even too is that like now everybody
wears masks our brand is already [ __ ]
it's weirdly [ __ ] in this funny ass
way again everything has for real i'm
not pissed off about it but like now
we're getting comments in our our
content we're wearing a mask and people
are like anti-masters or whatever
they're like you guys shouldn't be
wearing that you're promoting this isn't
that yeah and then you have other fans
going like are you [ __ ] new like yeah
they've been wearing it so it so all to
say all this [ __ ] sob [ __ ]
uh and how much crap happened to us
again i'm not complaining because
everybody went through it but like from
a dancer's angle and from our business
literally everything got killed
fully so so just feeling
you just feel failure you know what i
mean it's not your [ __ ] fault and
everybody's your closest friends in your
family who are so right trying to be
like it's not your you can't help it and
yeah and then even so that you're also
strong enough and like uh or you're
trying to be a good human being too so
you accept that and you you know you're
like you're like i know i know and you
let it be easy because you're not trying
to argue with another person how shitty
that is and then you go home and you
send your own thoughts where you get to
just argue with yourself and you don't
have to explain yourself to anybody and
you're like i [ __ ] feel like
if i didn't fail i'm at the bottom of
something
you know what i mean did you feel that
by yourself or did you feel it with nina
feel that with mike
um
i know that mike also felt his own
version
but uh
i think that
it wasn't like um
it wasn't like a fire happened around us
and then the fire ended so that you had
time to just sit in like destruction
yeah it's like the fire burned
everything but the fire still blazed
burning yeah so you're just like
i know everything sucks but i'm still
trying to put out fires so you keep
going it's like a a never-ending [ __ ]
breakup or something you know
something is happening yeah and the
irony with it is that like uh we joke
around because we end up getting a
residency at the row uh in downtown l.a
shortly after yeah
uh and that residency is done now it's
just a pop-up it made sense for them too
they were also doing rent abatement for
everybody they're not making money they
wanted somebody else to come in and do
some marketing as well and shout out to
the royal i might be semi dissing them
right now but the whole point is their
space is amazing [ __ ] yeah you know but
we could never afford it anyway so it
was just a dope trade-off at the time we
could bring in some people do some
classes do some marketing so that even
going on i we joke around now about that
was like um that's like when a rebound
girl
it's like we [ __ ] broke up with the
complex and it was so like this is so
terrible i need to have a rebound
otherwise i don't know how i'm gonna get
through it so just constantly trying to
just like you know tread water
in the disaster
got us through it and i'm proud that
like you know we kept our heads high and
we like tried to pull on momentum but i
definitely felt the lowest
version of something i have i haven't
felt that since like [ __ ] 2011 when i
got laid off broke up with my girlfriend
and had to move back home and i was in
my parents room you know what i'm saying
being like post college like i'm a loser
so wait at what point then so two
questions the first one is
where is the like where's the regret in
that right because what you're
explaining
i get that you're saying like
i i think i think i was um obviously
part of the side that pitched the vision
for the complex
the idea of like
i'm this i'm i'm a i'm chinese enough to
know that like you got to be logical and
practical with stuff you know you got to
like you know stick to certain routines
or like if it ain't fixed don't you know
or if anything broke don't like fix it
blah blah just little things that have
to be sensible but i also have this side
of maybe it's the gemini in me that like
understands it only crazy people do
crazy things oh it's the gemini for sure
yeah like if you if you don't have the
[ __ ] that crazy that loony in you
where people are looking at you like
what and you're not gonna accomplish
something crazy for good for better or
for worse so i knew that the complex was
a crazy thing but i was like nobody in
our industry nobody in our scene nobody
in our community the culture of dance
around that follows assault because the
world got smaller through social media
so everybody pays attention
but nobody's doing crazy things that
change what it means to be a person in
that scene you know what i mean like
yeah if people don't like see the people
the way that dancers look up to kendra's
i know a part of it is like
like we are the ones that just do [ __ ]
that doesn't make sense but suddenly we
make it sensible so like even arena
dance competition
we lost tens of thousands of dollars on
that every year people don't understand
the [ __ ] like the numbers basic math
when you look at an event like that
where you have one night of performances
only for one audience and all these
people that put in work and costumes
like and then a grand prize of ten
thousand dollars the only reason why we
did a ten thousand dollar grand prize
which guaranteed we were gonna be in the
red was because every other competition
at most at that time was either free the
winner of the dancers don't win [ __ ]
you know what i mean the biggest
competition is you would get a medal and
but you still have to pay to compete oh
[ __ ] right yeah and then at most the
next highest competition like twenty
five hundred dollars
as a grand prize so like [ __ ] this dude
dancers will never get the credit or the
respect they deserve if we don't go to
the illest venue have the sickest judges
and have the nastiest cash prize that's
what's going to tell people this is
worthy and that's what we did but we
lost money every time but that was the
whole point so even the complex was a
part of that we're not trying to make
dollars and profit off the things we're
trying to change the game and then maybe
profits will come from something bigger
right you guys get the coin uh the the
point of that and so i'm pitching the
complex like
we can't just do a dance studio what are
you pitching it to
our partners uh to our partners who have
to answer to investors as well so we're
all in it i'm not taking all the blame
or or success or whatever but the point
is like i definitely was like yo we're
gonna do this in la
we're gonna we're gonna get our
production house in it we're gonna be in
the heart we're gonna you know just make
this big ass thing and again i know it's
not my fault and it's out of my control
but like
the the business moves that you make you
you know in your own mind maybe if i
would have done this maybe if i would
have chosen cheaper location maybe if we
would have done this with the type of
deal maybe if we would have struck this
or made this call instead of the doj
like there are little things along the
way that you start kicking yourself and
ask for that if i would have just done
this slightly different
maybe we would be in a different place
and the thing is
nobody else has the power or the
authority or even the fiduciary duty to
do that so it's just on guys like me and
mike when you're at the top in that
sense yeah you're also on the top of
liability and decision making right so
it's like
that that's where again i i can't say
remorse or regret because um we are
where we are and whatever happened
happened right but there are for sure
moments where it's like
should we have made this concept should
we have done did we do this wrong and we
were probably either still paying for
those decisions now
or
or
we're gonna move it out the way until
there's clarity on like this had to
happen because yeah so it's really just
like where your mental fortitude is with
what you're willing to work with with
what you got so the only thing i can do
is now be [ __ ] optimistic because
i've i've never
i've never had to go through something
so intense from a business point but
like what are you gonna do like there's
no [ __ ] sitting crying you just yeah
pick up your [ __ ] and go you know and
fortunately
well here actually i'll i'll keep this
even soon you want to get close from a
business owner to a business owner and i
think i mentioned this to bart even off
you know camera but like you can again
you can't just
uh receive that much support or
partnership with people and then like
[ __ ] happens and then that's it oh it
wasn't my fault and wipe your hands
clean like yeah no you have to just like
a settlement for breaking the lease
there's compromise and it's like like
mike and i chose
with our with integrity as much
integrity as possible for a such a
drastic situation to salvage even the
relationship with partners who had to
like go and invest so much so we even
straight up we we gave up some equity of
of our own company of kenji's in order
to be like look i know that adventure
didn't go as planned but we want you to
know that that was never the point and
we want you to know we're literally
through our
actual action we're in it to the end
with you wow like you can have a piece
of what we are if you truly still
believe in us because i know we've we
didn't [ __ ] up but right
wow yeah that's that that's bad
but like you know we want to let you
know and and continue to have faith in
this partnership and this this is our
our compromise and like that was one of
the hardest things to do right like
imagine that giving up
a part of like yourself your baby uh for
for
for something you it wasn't your fault
yeah like that's how how deep that [ __ ]
goes you know so that's why it's
remorse regret again tough tough words
but you get it like you can't
go that far into the depth of like you
know your personal life even though it's
business without like having moments
real am i did i [ __ ] up am i doing the
right thing is this the right is this
the right thing yeah are we living the
right thing right now you know what i
mean like yeah you don't know but but
you just got to keep your head up and
stay you know
positive i guess yeah i mean no one
writes the playbook to
how to be a successful entrepreneur you
know and by definition of an
entrepreneur
you're starting a business or starting
an idea
of something that doesn't really exist
before so even the ways of when crisis
does happen the way you solve it is new
yeah you know it's like well usually
this happens but you're like
yeah that's with everything else that
has a business model set in place yeah
this is brand new
and
you know you know it felt right for you
guys to go hey just to have like a token
of like
of showing of appreciation to show
continued loyalty
here's a piece of us too [ __ ] just kind
of like how like in medieval times where
like you know like are my kids getting
to marry yours or in the mafia it's like
well
now i own your restaurant as well you
know it's just like you're just making
up it really is it really is like to
make sure everyone feels good about
where they're going
and because at the end of the day like
with all the stubbornness in the world
you're believing in something bigger
than that thing yeah i mean no matter
how much you're [ __ ] like that thing
is is worth to you
what you're actually trying to go for is
100 times bigger and the only way to get
there is to like make the right calls
have the right people you know now i
don't look at it as like we gave away a
part of ourselves it's like yo you gotta
[ __ ] build strategic partnerships
yeah you know you it's like you gotta
gang up you you know you jump going i
see this in the movies i'm not gangster
enough to say it but like you go into a
prison it's like you [ __ ] find a
click otherwise because if you stay by
yourself how are you gonna like survive
because the world is very very doggy dog
world uh and sometimes it's not even
people being like you know uh
having animosity with you sometimes the
world is just tough yeah you know what's
crazy is the more i do business and like
kind of like i guess rise in the levels
i start to meet different types of
people that are also doing business at
different levels and in the beginning i
think it's more
informal right it's like i have some
business ideas i share with you and you
tell me some of your trials and
tribulations that we kind of learn from
each other and then as like the zeros
grow on your like gross revenue there's
more formalized versions there's like
masterminds there's like secret business
groups and then you start to understand
that they they all like wanna be in a
certain group and they're like oh wait
that company is started by this
celebrity but it's actually
there's other 10 other celebrities that
also own this they also cross promote
it's like this giant orchestrated thing
and you're just like man like that's the
only way to if you really want to get to
that next next next level it's
it's how many people are in your phone
contacts that can really help grow
everyone and that's just insane
and then and then there's also there's
also the uh
mo money mo problems essence yep um
i
again humbly feel like i'm edging on to
learning the depths
of more money
that's nice which is which is sick in
one ways
uh but
i mean we do business with friends
yeah you know what i'm saying so like
we
like
holding on to statutes and making sure
especially because like when you're like
again when you're ceos when you're
running a company
you can't constantly give people context
and communication everybody is like
fully fully on board and understanding
every decision that has to be made
especially when the company needs to
move quickly involves a lot of other
people when you're answering to other
partners and investors it's like at the
end of the day a few can run fast and
move this thing well yeah but that also
means that there's just room for lack of
communication understanding or people
even like you know um or not even in the
full context yeah you know and to see
even for us and i speak from uh you know
with more clarity on this even for us
like people probably still to this to
this day like kenji is like a dance team
and i get that like that's still most of
like what people are receiving and and
what we project but ultimately kendra's
is also a business right so there's a
whole business behind it and what once
was so clearly so clearly a dance crew
is now so much more than a dance crew i
barely even [ __ ] rehearse unless i
have to you know because there's so much
[ __ ] already for work for jobs or for
social media or content creation versus
just the crew stuff that we do you know
so
to have what
was once a dance crew that everybody
kind of you know in their own way had
like equity in or like was very active
and a part of and influential in but now
to look for us to be like running
businesses that include like talk shows
and and noodles or this or that you know
what i mean it's just such a different
place yeah so when
success or when other things may come in
also finding the way to navigate and
make sure that everybody is uh fairly
you know a part of and stays and has the
ability to be a part of but like at a
professionally
fair way like yeah i guess i'll be
swimming in that for the next few years
and and i know that that's a growing
part of like what it is for my journey
you know again i'm thankful that i can
even like
begin to understand that space but uh
yeah i gotta admit there's there's some
there's some pressure that's going on
there's some other things that we got to
start working through in order to make
sure that we do stuff the right way
because we care about each other you
know what i'm saying so even with
business you gotta you gotta work extra
hard when you're with friends and family
absolutely absolutely because it's um
you also have to keep an account the
knowledge um
that everyone has in terms of business
right because it's like if everyone's
doing different things like you can't go
into
like the apparel factory and just be
like this is the way this these these
things need to be done and they're like
no no that's not it at all this is the
way it should be done and now you're
pissed because you don't understand what
they're saying and they're going no but
trust me this is the right way to do it
you know so that's
also really uh really hard managing
micromanaging expectations and and all
in history yeah and you know i mean
we know yeah i know y'all know i mean i
know like you know i've i've been
fortunate enough to at least still be
consistent in your guys relationship for
a [ __ ] decade now pretty much tick
tick tick was 2011. oh [ __ ] tick tick
that's 2011 that was a tour that we did
of australia yeah and that's when we
first met was it 2011 i think that was
2011.
that's all i'm saying tick tick tour we
were there with like poreotics uh j.r
aquino the architects uh with puspos in
them and uh we had who else was there
johnny
yeah uh
who else was yo ma i was there with your
mama crew
oh yeah lawrence right yeah with
lawrence basically for the jk films
representation was y'all two joe and
casey right yeah is there anybody else
there no we were the main four
so that was that's literally
so you get it yeah i don't know what we
get at the beginning of the journey 10
years later
i'm still fortunate to be rolling with
y'all but
people change life situations change you
know what i mean and again same thing
bringing it back to it
when you go through a pandemic
so many individual situations change so
even just trying to like
properly and respectfully work with and
adapt to those things like that in and
of itself is a challenge you know yeah
like back then when we said like years
ago when you called kendra's rehearsal
it's easy nobody's married nobody's got
children yeah people are living in this
in the city you know what i mean the
hustle's still on yeah there's no hour
that they're thinking about dancing all
the time they don't have to you know
what i mean now it's like when we try to
schedule one thing we gotta schedule
early in advance like make sure your kid
gets daycare make sure you guys are in
town make sure you're not already on
that convention make sure that you know
what i'm saying
it's it's a whole different world now
but um yeah i don't know either way it's
where we're meant to be and and it's all
a blessing for the ride with all the
stuff that you guys that you've gone
through
um
and all the skills that you've acquired
and even like the the mental fortitude
and like the tenacity the will the
emotional stability to be able to handle
big problems
with all of that
if like let's say
um
ken just ended
or like let's say there's a genie that
shows up and it was like
hey you can be the same person you are
and have the same exact skills
and i can put you back in
2011 or 2012 or whatever
um would you do the exact same route as
ken just or would you go here's
what i think would have been a better
route or better decision does everyone's
memory get wiped yeah that's everyone's
memory every that's that mine everyone's
memory including yours
wait so then but he still has the life
skills and everything yeah oh [ __ ]
damn let me get this let me get in on
this job i don't have memory of what we
did but i just have the skills actually
you have you're the only one in the
mirror okay i'm the only one okay yeah
and not mike song
no that's funny as well cause he's just
my my co-pilot
i have the memory of it okay
a long story short no i would not do
everything in the same way for sure for
sure would it still be kendra's
it would still be kendra's it would
still be in dance
it would just start this would still be
the vehicle i see dance was for sure
still be the viewer would you start the
cultural
movement sooner
um one remember in 2010 when we started
kendra's it was our side project joke
so we were all individually doing
kindred i mean doing our thing traveling
at all
we didn't start as a crew well remember
even in 2011 when we met you didn't see
kendricks you saw yo mama so it was all
just side [ __ ] yeah you know i'm saying
kendra's didn't become a business
until 2014 end of 2014 i think you guys
just sat down they had good creatives
because they did ambu black ops too
which i thought was a real thing like
they were just doing things that were
branded very well so i think any [ __ ]
around thing could have been like oh
that's going to take off yeah everything
looked like it was going to take off
yeah but but it wasn't that so i think
for like
for the sake
of the sake and the fun of this
conversation let me get to the
nitty-gritty all right number one for
sure the business would have just
business mentality should have just
started way faster we were [ __ ] up to
the point where when we first started
selling merchandise okay this this is
this is called business 101 learning
through life [ __ ] don't do it when we
were [ __ ] selling merchandise we did
not charge tax for california sales in
the beginning because you guys were
trying to because we didn't [ __ ] know
oh no
you don't learn basic [ __ ] like this you
have to learn it through mistake and we
just made some random basic mistakes so
yeah when we
when we suddenly think that we're doing
like you know maybe we did like i don't
know maybe like 150 000 in sales that
first year and uh x amount was
california but then suddenly we owed
like ten thousand something in taxes
that we just had no idea where it came
from you're just like
the [ __ ] right so that's one thing yeah
okay
and then same thing with most of us has
to do with business one-on-ones always
redo one [ __ ] the
learning the wrong way our first year of
getting hit with taxes
oh my god i would have [ __ ] fixed our
our payout situation so much smarter or
even like in some of the other
situations where right now like the type
of human work contracts that i would
have had the the the waiver insurance
waivers the workers comp statements the
w9 so you would have done like sooner
and just organized like those ended up
being the things that you would still go
in business i would i would just be
better at it and not [ __ ] because when
you make mistakes you're you're
backpedaling or you lose money or you
lose time or i'm put into a situation
where i can't be creative because i'm
focusing on [ __ ] that we [ __ ] up on
you know i'll take those mistakes to
heart all day but still like if you're
saying i had the skills to go back in
time [ __ ] yeah i would avoid the
mistakes
you guys on jk news like the way my dad
dates now it's like exactly the first
day questions are so straight up do you
own a house
are you in debt is your kid in college
do you pay for that
do you are you a felon
like it's very cold but logistical stuff
and then when i was talking to you guys
about that on my drive back home i kind
of had like a slight epiphany
and when you're younger and more
just when you're younger i guess or more
naive i think
your emotional drive is so strong that
it
kind of like
it kind of like i don't even know what
the right word is but euphemisizes like
the logistical part of things right yeah
yeah i know but then when you get older
and you've
gotten your ass handed to you a billion
times it's almost like let me make sure
my logistics are on point so that my
emotional can come at the end and it
will be untouched
let me give you an exact you're
absolutely right i'll give you exact
example of how i would use that in the
kindred history yeah it would have been
[ __ ] abdc
right instead of or or even nbc world of
dance uh nbc world dance is actually
better because i'm still proud of what
we did on abc but we see world of dance
right instead of thinking we need to
like
preserve the artistry and the culture
and the integrity of who we are as
people and make sure that we tell our
story the right way and blah blah it's
like dude this is not a [ __ ] real
competition
just go out there and smash fools
stop trying to just be like like this is
who king is this is who we are this is
where we come from this is our uh asian
american experience like this is the one
time that we can get on a microphone in
front of the world and share something
true
yes
but not
totally yeah you know what i mean
instead of like coming out with like
that last routine that we would have did
we did it to like work song or whatever
we always come out with these like
really emotional things i'd be like you
know what just [ __ ] dude let's go hip
hop not give a [ __ ] you know and just
like just rip rolls [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah just literally battle mentality
only should have just had john hodges
choreographing it's hard
instead of that other soft stuff that's
my fault but you know what i'm saying
like moments like that
where you get caught up
you know in the in that
yeah but if you were
in retrospect obviously it's always
easier in retrospect but if you look
back now and that's the whole point of
this conversation being able to go back
it's like that logistical like what do i
just need to do
to get this done the right way and then
everything out there after that that's
the emotional stuff that we can enjoy
you know what i'm saying yeah so uh easy
easy would totally still do the same
thing but would just crush it way
smarter
and not [ __ ] around with taxes the wrong
way guys like
you're so funny dude you're such a
different person
like um
when we met obviously we were all in the
same boat we were all younger we didn't
have families like not that we were
short-sighted by any means but just our
priorities were different like yes we
knew we want families yes we know we
wanted to settle down whatever but like
when you're in the thick of it right and
you're building this dream or this idea
or whatever this universe is that you
want to live in um
you're
like you're just like this creative free
spirit like let me just try this and
doing whatever right and that's how you
were but now you're just so like
you're like just this businessman dude
no he's giving me the genie though
that's not fair though no just in
general yeah well i also think you have
to
that's dope it's an evolutionary dream
everyone's driven by this emotion by
this passion that is bound by no rules
it's just your ideal right
but then when you're given tools
there's very specific tools right yeah
some pound some rotate some you know are
double-sided tape and now it's like oh
wait my dream wasn't bound by these
three types of things yeah so now like
when you're like well then if i have to
rebuild a dream
let me see what tools i have first do i
have a glue gun or what okay that then
now i know okay what to build off of
yeah so i i definitely and i'm saying
that and a man's only as loyal as his
options in one sense uh where it's like
even today like i have i'm like i could
easily sit here right now yeah business
this of course i would do it like that
but
the experiential life liver in us all is
still like if somebody came with a dance
job right they're like here's this job
and the rate sucks the deal sucks the
memo sucks how much i have to work is
like intense but then they're like oh
but you get to go to this country and
i'm like [ __ ] but i've never been in
that country
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what
i'm saying like
i'm still like and that's that's what
the last 10 years was for us like yeah
you know
i've been to over i think i've been to
like 35 countries now you know what i
mean that was one of the sickest life
experiences i'll always be able to have
yeah you know what i mean i'm like i
will never regret that even though i
pushed off certain things i know we
always have these conversations where
it's like maybe it wasn't the right
business move at the time maybe i should
have kept a certain hustle but it's like
getting the worldly perspective and just
being like i have seen some [ __ ] also
gives you a different like you know
whatever and i know time and time again
i'm still gonna do that like even if
this makes hella sense like dude don't
go because like you can keep it a better
business flow or whatever
if a [ __ ] opportunity knocks on the
door that derails everything but it's
like this is a crazy opportunity right
yeah
so i i don't know i got to walk through
the door you have to
so like
that's also what i think life is or else
we'll all be robots which is why which
is why in the in the scenario
because we keep our memories i can make
those calls yeah but if i didn't keep my
marriage and i only got the experience i
still might make the same
or maybe that's why maybe that's why i'm
leading towards things like taxes
because i'm like i would change that no
emotions yeah because that's like one
thing that's black and white yeah i
[ __ ] up yeah yeah but it's not like i
would not go to this trip or make this
decision because like that gave me my
life experience or memory you know what
i mean i remember when we first got hit
with taxes and it's like you know like
people like gary vee and like all the
business self entrepreneur like that
that type of world has been around for a
long time and it's always pitched go
work for yourself why why would you
spend 40 hours dedicated someone else is
that person dedicated like you hear all
those memes all the time right and it's
like cool i'm gonna be an entrepreneur
i'm gonna build this empire or whatever
and then when once you get hit with
taxes you're like
this is why you want to work a nine to
five they take it out for you you're
chill you don't have to worry about it
and it never comes at you at a good time
you know like with your 100 grand merch
it probably came at you here's a 15 000
bill you have to pay this tax but also
the next shipment that's coming in
that's gonna pay for next rent uh next
month's rent it's also 15 000 and you
also have to pay for that what are you
gonna do you know it's literally and
then you're like
oh my god and then you're like hey nina
you know that one trip that we're gonna
do i think we might have to wait until
like april uh so you're talking about me
anita's wedding
oh i don't even know i mean but it's
like that right when it's like when when
when you're a business owner you
i mean it's if you're doing it at least
decent you have a couple of funds that
you can tap into
but or cushions
but there's a lot of self-sacrifice dude
that's that's exactly what i'm saying uh
me and nina's wedding because like you
know and thank you for the
congratulations we got [ __ ] engaged
this year
this year february by the way at the
club the week that we closed the complex
and that was the only thing that kept us
all going by the way like
everybody was [ __ ] heartbroken and
didn't and the energy was super weird
and the second i was like guys i think
i'm gonna use this last performance to
propose
suddenly everybody has something to do
they're like okay we gotta clean this
out we gotta do this make sure moving's
the next day we'll make sure we finish
you know what i mean like the energy was
cool but
after that it's been a constant barrage
of when you guys getting married when
you guys getting married when you guys
getting married and we even went out and
danced for nothing trust me don't even
let that get to you because once you get
married then the next question you know
what that is yeah yeah kids absolutely
of course of course questions don't stop
it
but those are exciting those are things
that i want so it's like cool but it's
uh to your point in terms of especially
like that self-sacrifice and like as a
business owner too yeah right it's like
i we went [ __ ] uh wedding so we're
not wedding shopping but like you know
she's like like the dresses like we went
to like different venues like venue
shopping kind of went to like maui we
checked out some venues
right the whole thing please make it a
mountain please i want you to i want to
do but we're assuming we're invited by
the way
the maui might be a family one because
of money because you know like literally
that's what we're there we're gonna pay
a tax i'll tell you the dates i'll tell
you the dates
but the point is like even after all
that
the only decision we ended up making was
this hold off
so we're not even gonna have a wedding
next year we're looking at 2023 and the
irony is that like now that like you
know kobe is like chilling out and
people are having weddings again going
to all my homies weddings and like you
know it's dope because like everybody in
there
um i don't want to say it's like this
but like people that maybe don't have as
entrepreneurial lives right it's like
easier to like have a flow or like the
nine to five or whatever
predictable schedules yeah that's the
attraction from it like after having
become an entrepreneur
like me and her like because we're a
family now i have all kinds of plan b c
d e f g like plants yeah in case [ __ ]
happens or whatever and probably like
after plan b like c through e they're
all nine to five jobs
just so i can have some stability and
have and be able to have the mental
bandwidth you know nine to five concept
jobs yeah yeah yeah not like you're
going to be an employee to somebody yeah
no not employees that's what you're
doing
yes like i was like maybe i'll be like a
force ranger oh yeah
that's pretty cool i clock in i clock
out i still i'm in nature i do what i
like i have benefits
that sounds kind of good yeah no i
understand my dad wants to be i wanted
to be a mailman for a long time after he
like retired but yeah but but even to
that point though it's like it's not
even just like uh
like i don't have money to get married
like if i wanted to really throw a
wedding yeah one i'm just like it's not
financially sensible compared to like
how much it costs relative to like how
much i actually have and then two i'm
like
i'm like i'm either over leveraged or
i'm like all my money's in investments i
could pull money out of an investment
whether it be like you know a real
estate interest
investment trust here whether it be you
know my retirement fund here whether it
be crypto here whether it be private
equity investment here so i'm like
lucky to have different opportunities to
be invested in but then it's like i'm
like
imagine with crypto i was like i could
pull out that money but i'm like i'm
locked in a really good position so it's
like what is the actual life play
because society is saying it's not right
for the plugin right society's telling
you like there's a time frame you should
do stuff uh even after you're engaged or
you're supposed to spend this much on a
ring [ __ ] that [ __ ] or the type of
wedding suppose i know you guys are you
guys are the most gangster out of this
so to sit here and talk to you guys
about how you
[ __ ] just did your thing that's get a
tattoo
when she came back home with that i was
like can you believe you're a [ __ ]
mom dude that's like i'm starting bjj
like at 38 years old like most people my
age are going like oh i can't do this
thing like my bones hurt and i'm like yo
i'm trying to wreck you i'm trying to
[ __ ] break like knock people out yeah
so just like all of that
which which is constantly around right
so you do you it's you can't ignore it
you know no i don't want to call it
societal pressure it's society
right like everyone's doing that um but
to like but it's if you see yourself in
that societal space you know what i mean
so like i hear it all the time right
like when you're having second kid or
just the age thing or because i'm a
woman or whatever um but i don't
see myself in their space
i feel you i feel like what i mean so
like that's why i don't feel these
pressures of like i should be doing this
or that because i'm like well who's the
person telling me that are they are they
my kind of people because if they're not
then because your question to them is
like when are you going to get your next
tattoo you're 37. you should have at
least three yeah yeah i mean you know
what i mean like if it's not the caliber
of people that i admire or am inspired
by or the life lane that you want to go
exactly you know then then for me it's
like oh [ __ ] that's just not my path
which is exactly why i brought you guys
on my show today and that's why i'm so
i'm so close i get close to people like
you dude
because even though the rest of sight is
that it's like i gotta i gotta hang out
with barton geo because i they're
[ __ ] weird
honestly [ __ ] the normal stuff but like
that that is what you need to do right
like everybody what is it people always
say like you're honestly exactly you're
a reflection of your like you're close
to seven people or whatever yeah so you
gotta be [ __ ] conscious of who you
keep in your circle because they rub off
on you yeah you know what i'm saying
that's why i literally like had to
like i i'm pretty uh
not confrontational but like i'm i'm i'm
pretty uh front-facing or forward about
asking questions sometimes like like how
how did i become how did i become the
host of jk news
we were
me and joe were talking about who would
be good candidates to be the next host
and we're just like bouncing ideas back
and forth out loud and he was hearing
this i mean like we're i mean jk's like
a family right so we're always talking
out loud all the time there's more
there's there was more dramatic than
that
and then like i see it was more like
steve was getting a lot of pressure
because like he he stepped in and he had
to like fill a hole he's already been
hosting but then now if he's hosting uh
like three days straight we're literally
taking his strength away from him and
it's not his full-time thing either yeah
yeah yeah and so anthony was just like
hey i don't want to be too forward or
anything but this is what i'm hearing
i'd be down a host
and i thought that was [ __ ] dope yeah
and like
in my in my mind
just to add fun consciousness
done and they were like okay
because me and joe hate talks like this
so we're like done let's go for a walk
yeah it's so fast which i was like oh
[ __ ] but like from where i'm coming from
too like um
i'm like finally after like years of
coming i was i was at jk news in the
beginning as a guest you know what i
mean like really wants to start i was
like oh you guys are doing a new show
too we're getting roasted
i get roasted way more i
[Applause]
for sure
number one roasted guy right now like
there's a season
it hurts so bad but i get it because
like maybe it's because like i'm very
fortunate there's really cool things
happening but because there's cool
things happening your closest friends
have to stay positive bro that's
probably why they're making fun of you
yeah if anything if [ __ ] starts really
getting worse for me i think they'll
stop but
anyways so like i'm also a position
where i'm like i'm uh usually when i
wanted to come back on jk news i would
always have to hit up like barter
whoever you know was hosting and like
hey i'm in town for a couple weeks
because that was that was the thing it's
just i never [ __ ] knew my schedule i
was literally gone over 50 percent of
your traveling teaching performing
choreographing whatever the [ __ ] so it
was inconsistent even for nina so when i
come home i'm like hey i got a couple i
got a couple weeks can i be on jq news
and that was me always trying to know
that this uh you know that was a space
whether it be the group of people the
type of thing that i was doing that was
like something i wanted to stay a part
of like what i do otherwise i would
because even when when it comes to just
dancing if i just create dance concepts
most of the stuff i actually gravitate
towards in music and dance is actually a
lot more like deep uh you know ethereal
emotional type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying and if people only got that from
me they'd probably
not know anything about me i'm [ __ ]
ridiculous you know you guys get me i'm
like a goon you know
good one thank you thank you but the
point is like having stuff like jk i was
like dude this is
almost healthy for me right and then so
finally again with a pandemic here
here's silver lining
i was forced to stay home
so finally getting a chance to be like
oh like i i want to do more jk and then
you know one thing led to another and
it's like the right time and then and it
was like uh come on and be a regular and
i was like i was like oh [ __ ] i'm a
regular and i was like
i really like this i'm pretty good at it
you know what i mean and also again like
i had mentioned earlier all the dance
work was cut out from under me too
you know like uh
i had to
if i wanted i i cut my own salary like
you know i had to
change it
so so i even was like oh [ __ ] like i
even had to look at jk a little bit like
a job for real frill yeah yeah
so then
having to rework the wires in my mind i
was like okay even if i look at this for
real even like as a job then i need to
like do a great job i can't i don't get
to in a sense don't be uh i can't be a
guest to this yeah you know what i'm
saying even to be
promoted if you it's like a regular i
got to treat this like with my like the
respect i would treat if it was my own
[ __ ] i do feel that though when you show
up i feel like a sense of pride in your
work and a professionalism that you like
to carry even though we [ __ ] around and
we go crazy
i do feel like
between the minutes that were like
actioned and cut
you do really try to bring it and you
never ever go on like the passive end or
just let the subconscious go you know i
do feel it i appreciate it i appreciate
it well i appreciate it man thanks for
giving me a spot there you know because
again that's like i i find so much joy
in it so i have to treat it with respect
but even you know the to
where we even got there like just to try
and be forward knowing that those are
good things i need in my life and being
willing you don't need to look at
somebody and put yourself in that
vulnerable because at the end of the day
you could say no yeah and i could just
right there just that's it yeah you know
what i mean whether it's asking to even
be a guest hey i'm available it's like i
got space for you that that can happen
at any time yeah or as ford is like hey
like i'm down to be a host like have a
role in this i like how you did that
that's why you'll never fail dude
just whatever you gotta go for it yeah
you're never gonna fail man and and you
gotta
you know really
just be real with yourself and identify
people that bring you up because people
you kick it with on the daily aren't
always going to exactly be the same
people that like
challenge you and and make you a better
version of yourself that's totally
different that's forced you to grow yeah
there's like a hangout version that
doesn't have to be
progress always you don't always have to
win life you know what i'm saying yeah
but you have to know
that like winning life is a thing and
you have to progress and the only people
like if i'm at the uh if i'm the most
noob in like my closest seven that's a
great place to be that means that means
i have the most to learn and everybody's
helping me out and the the irony is that
i think uh maybe this is truly the life
journey too the irony is like i said
when we were at that spot when we were
having that meeting with nike at the
grand opening the complex and all that
stuff i felt like i was the top guy for
everybody sick in my circle which is i
felt really proud of it yeah right i'm
the guy who's he's teaching people who's
leading people who's pulling people
farther than their own ambitions and
your patrol leader exactly senior patrol
here and the funny thing is in life
right now
even though of course i still have to
hold that position
the funny thing is i actually feel like
a [ __ ] noob right now i've never been
so handed like like just like on my ass
all the time just getting rocked by the
intensity of like where
life's next step is it can be in
business it can be in marriage and
having children it could be in looking
at real estate and seeing it different
i'm not i'm not coming into you guys
how's me impressed like oh it's so big
i know a lot of your personal stories
and how it got here and i look at the
whole the lineage i look at your
glendora house i look at the first house
of me and lawrence were gay as [ __ ]
with you guys and stuff wherever that
was you know what i mean and and i i see
that
and and that's what i'm impressed with
when i see this house thank you you feel
me this [ __ ] again dude that's
why i brought you guys onto my show guys
get close
okay so
i mean we've been talking for a really
long time
no we can keep going and i love where
it's going
but we just have to close it out so
we've been talking for a really long
time and i absolutely like dude the last
time we hung out we hung out in the jk
office no noise no music no nothing and
we were we were just [ __ ] having the
best time ever yeah i finally like drank
with bart a little bit yes it was dope i
mean you're just dope company you're a
dope spirit we [ __ ] love you we're so
[ __ ] proud of you
yes you feel like you're being knocked
on your ass right now but i'm so excited
for you like i know the type of person
that you are and i know that whatever it
is that you're gonna do you're gonna
[ __ ] smash it and it's gonna be so
sick so i cannot wait to see where all
this [ __ ] leads because it's like yes
you're on your ass but that just means
you're just gonna grow and learn
and bro yeah i'm excited uh i i admire
and i look up to you so much yes that on
one of our jk
walks
um and i know like our life paths are a
little bit different right now you're in
l.a i'm in vegas you're still like
super
in the whole like building your cultural
empire thing and so are we um so we
don't our bandwidths are completely full
but when you said that we have to do
something together one day and i said
yes done
i know it's gonna happen i don't know
when but i love you like a brother and i
know it's gonna happen he means it yeah
i mean that means a lot dude i love you
guys both like family i'm very thankful
for y'all and we are doing it you guys
here on my podcast that i just started
yeah so make sure you follow my new
podcast get close i'm uh i'm your guest
host i'm probably gonna take a big break
after this because this is such a great
one i'll leave it in these two hands
you're so funny but thank you for being
on here uh thank you for loving us
because if you didn't like i mean you're
a busy ass person like you wouldn't
we we know that you just don't do [ __ ]
for the sake of doing [ __ ] so thank you
and we love you love you okay
bye